spider-man far from home is officially
out in theaters and there is a lot to
break down including the final battle
with spider-man and Mysterio and the mid
and post credit scene so let's get right
into it
and clearly there will be some spoilers
in this video for spider-man far from
home so if you have not seen the movie
you may want to click away now also if
you would like a chance to win a Captain
America shield an Iron Man helmet and
Infinity Gauntlet or another Marvel
Legends item be sure to subscribe to my
channel to enter my giveaway I'll be
picking three winners at four hundred
and fifty thousand subscribers the final
battle takes place in London on the
Tower Bridge Mysterio is creating the
illusion that all of the elementals have
combined and are attacking London he
creates this illusion with a combination
of his own technology and drones by
stark industry which he controls using
Edith what she got from Peter Parker who
got it from Tony Stark Mysterio's plan
is to make it seem like he defeated this
monster elemental therefore making him
the greatest hero of all time but of
course here comes spider-man to the
rescue jumping right out of Tony Stark's
plane that happy hogan is flying
equipped with his new suit that he just
built Peter begins to destroy the drones
which eventually leads to the illusion
disappearing spider-man thing goes to
fight Mysterio one-on-one and Mysterio
tries to trap him in another illusion
but spider-man uses his spidey senses or
what they call in the movie his Peter
tingle to defeat the drones that were
protecting Mysterio Mysterio uses an
illusion to make it seem like he has
been hit by gunfire from one of the
drones and tries to sneak up from behind
on Peter and shoot him point-blank in
the head but luckily for spider-man his
Peter tingle kicked in and he was able
to sense what was happening and defended
himself Peter then takes control back
over Edith and stops all of the drones
from attacking the city and his friends
Mysterio now severely injured and about
to die says with his final breath the
people will believe what they want to
believe this leads us into the mid
credit scene the mid-credits scene
starts with spider-man and MJ swinging
through the city MJ of course is still
terrified they land and MJ says I'm
never doing that again Peter says I
should probably get out of here and as
he leaves a news reporter comes on a
giant screen in downtown New York the
reporter says that we have revelation on
last week's attack in London
was provided by an anonymous source but
shows Quintin Beck aka Mysterio moments
before his death they then show a video
that has been edited to make it seem
like spider-man is the bad guy Mysterio
says that he managed to send the
elementals back through the dimensional
rift but spider-man attacked him for no
reason using an army of stark tech
drones the news reporter then says that
this video was released earlier on in
the day by the Daily Bugle net the Daily
Bugle then pops up on the screen and we
see the one and only Jay jonah Jameson
played by the one and only JK Simmons
from the very first spider-man films he
gets on the screen saying that Mysteria
will go down as one of the greatest
heroes ever in history but then he says
that's not all and then it cuts to the
video of Quentin Beck saying that
spider-man's true identity is Peter
Parker and then it shows a picture of
him exposing the fact that Peter is
spider-man to the whole entire world
it ends with Peter saying what the and
then it cuts just like it did with Aunt
May and spider-man homecoming and that's
the end of the first mid-credits scene
one thing to really note here is that
Quentin didn't just throw spider-man
under the bus he made sure to mention
Stark Industries we learned throughout
the film that he used to work for Tony
Stark and he hates him he hates him and
he hates Stark Industries which is why
he threw that name out there so the
world would turn not only against Peter
Parker and spider-man but against Stark
Industries as well so the future just
got really rough for spider-man and
Stark Industries the post-credits scene
shows Nick Fury and Maria Hill driving
in a car but as it turns out it's
actually not Nick Fury and Maria hill
it's Talos and his wife as it turns out
throughout the whole entire movie in
spider-man far from home Nick Fury and
Maria Hill were Talos and his wife the
whole entire time Tallis's wife says you
have to tell him meaning everything that
just happened Talos has to call Nick
Fury and tell him what happened
Talos says it was fine the little boy
handled it we helped a little bit and
says how was I supposed to know that the
whole thing was fake after his wife
persists again that he should call Nick
Fury he ends up calling him he said that
everything kind of fell apart and people
keep asking where the Avengers are and I
don't know what to say to that Nick Fury
seemingly on a beach then Hanks up on
him he then gets up and it shows that
the beach is actually a hologram and he
is on a scroll ship of some sort now
when he gets off the phone he talks to
everybody like he's in charge which
makes me believe that he could be at the
peak orbital headquarters of sword sword
stands for sentient world observation
and response department so this post
credit scene which may not seem like a
lot could be the introduction of sword
into the MCU so be sure to comment with
what you thought about spider-man far
from home the mid and post credits
scenes also be sure to LIKE the video
and subscribe to my channel if you'd
like to enter my marvel legends items
giveaway and so you can stay up to date
on everything relating to the MCU as
always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff